apparently this is my London look I
don't know I spilled an entire diet
cherry coke in a taxi cool trip so far
so guys don't know I am in London doing
a super-secret project out here and then
also doing a couple new filter shows
with mamrie and Hannah and so I'm out
here now and I've been this Hobbit o of
a hotel room teeny tiny little beds
they're great it's not gonna get any
better so today I decided that I would
show you guys what I bring with me when
I travel I travel with this backpack and
it's got cheering come from all over the
bottom let's see what's in here
deodorant loo good instant shower an
empty box of pepto-bismol Oh a Ricola
bag she's just good to have this around
I found the cup of Islam some reason I
have my tinted moisturizer in there and
some Burt's Bees chapstick I should look
in here more often
necklace hair yo reakless two tampons
you know when it's gonna start raining
blood an empty Splenda packet always
helpful get phones another empty Splenda
packet a variety of business cards if
you give me your business cards this is
where they go they come with me
everywhere oh ring ooh and trash now
let's look at this thing
oh god isn't this the most fun video
ever aren't you glad that you're using
your time to watch this dry shampoo
another very similar necklace I should
diversify my style lotion that makes me
appear tanner oh I got this new scent
from Kiehl's and it's vanilla sandalwood
or cedar wood or something wood it's
like a sugar boner just my head size
bronzer oh good another bronzer event
another camp Oh
hums I guess when I go away my stomach
also goes away
this was my bit from the last nofilter
show a mysterious blue liquid I'm
assuming that your toner or not
mouthwash but I'm not going to
experiment my dildo just a great video
guys my other dildo for my hair and then
a bunch of these cloths so there you go
there's a little insight into what I
bring with me when I travel was this
helpful at all for you I don't think it
was I think this made you worse we
should re-evaluate our time can we spend
together
so I just ate a salmon cream cheese
cucumber sandwich I would not feel good
pepto-bismol at skin it come in handy
yeah I don't know
so I see that why did I do that but also
why is why why are you why and what is I
don't know what that is but it's here
hanging out with me